squeezed between mountains on one side
and a lock on the other Faslane on the
scottish west coast has been the home of
the UK's nuclear deterrent for half a
century every few months a vanguard
class submarine quietly slips off into
the Clyde and out of sight that's the
last anyone will see of it until it
returns to base the UK has four of these
nuclear submarines there is always one
at sea 365 days a year giving that
constant deterrent to the United Kingdom
they usually patrol around the North
Atlantic moving very slowly very quietly
so they're not detected by the Russians
the order to fire a nuclear weapon would
come direct from the Prime Minister on
board deep under the North Atlantic the
crew would go through a series of well
rehearsed steps for launch the final act
would be to remove this red trigger from
a coded safe and squeeze we train quite
a lot so for about 50 percent of every
patrol will endure take what's called
red X and written exercise where we'll
simulate being a pirate in the States
and simulate being at 15 minutes notice
- farmer the farmers house on patrol the
submarine has little contact with the
outside world family can send messages
of a hundred and twenty words once a
week but the crew cannot reply
communication could give their position
away to the enemy you can drink on board
but I'd do a six hour on six hour of
shift and you won't find any members of
the ship's company especially junior
rates drinking while you're on a six on
six hour shift nuclear weapons are as
controversial as they are powerful for
decades a peace camp across the road
from the base has kept up the protest
there are only nine countries arguably
in the world that have nuclear weapons
the other hundred and ninety odd don't
have nuclear weapons
are they at greater risk than us I
suggest that they're at less risk than
us because they don't have nuclear
weapons the next generation of Britain's
nuclear deterrent are being built now
they will be operational by 2030
extending the UK's deterrent for another
50 years the four submarines will cost
in excess of a hundred and fifty billion
pounds over their lifetime the high
price for the ultimate insurance policy
alistair bungle Sky News Faslane in
Scotland